the jurogan experience well we live in a
crazy age
it's fun but stressful stress for a lot
of people well and for your study for
the study of human life extension
and anti-aging when you look at the
stresses that are completely
they're very novel to the human
experience like the stresses of social
media the stresses of cell phone use
the stresses of blue light like staring
at screens at night like all that stuff
like how much of an effect do you think
that's having on people and have we even
quantified that yet
uh we are quantifying it and it's having
a real negative effect mental health
issues
is going to be the medical problem of
the 21st century no question
there are companies that are doing these
uh remote
video chats with a psychologist or
psychiatrist
they are booming these are the next
billion dollar companies
yeah i mean you want to anyone want to
make money look into that
but we are living in a stressful world
and we part of it's because we don't
have much else to worry about we've
gotten rid of
all the major worries wolves yeah we
don't have to we're not in savannah
anymore we're not going to get picked
off by
uh a cheater well a lion probably but
we've built this world
we you know six million years ago the
first hominid ape-like thing
was up in the tree walking around
actually upright which is interesting
right wasn't swinging from the branches
that picked up a stick that animal
picked up a stick and that was put us on
this treadmill where we are today
innovation after innovation tool after
tool after tool but in response our
bodies have deteriorated
we only build our bodies as much as we
need to so if we've got tools
and we can throw rocks we don't need a
lot of muscles and in fact our head just
expanded so we could build better tools
faster and faster
and you know the culmination of that is
an iphone but where are we going to be
in another 100 000 years it's really
scary because this treadmill
we cannot get off it there's no going
back there's no stationary
because we've got problems that we've
already created from our own technology
that we have to solve with better
technology
so that we're a species that once we've
picked up that stick we're on this path
and those things that got us here there
are actually four traits that i think
can think of that got us here
that make us different from all other
animals those are our
not just our what got us here they're
our biggest threat
and but we also have to use them to get
us out of this problem
and what are those well let's see so the
first one is tool making okay no big
deal we've got hands that have evolved
to throw rocks shoes
um our feet actually are built for shoes
imagine that they're all these jeans
that we've
our feet are built for shoes yeah yeah
our feet actually
are we've had shoes for so many years
that we've got
feet that fit shoes have you ever seen
what it looks like when those guys in
the amazon walk around with no feet
and they develop these hand-like feet oh
they don't pick up stuff
oh no you have to see this because what
happens is when they walk around
barefoot in the dirt
for so long their toes develop the
ability to grip
so they're gripping the ground so their
toes instead of being like a person who
wears shoes all the time where the toes
are all connected
they splay out like hands that's
very strange makes sense i want i want
that my friend steve vanello was in
guyana and he was uh hanging out with
his tribe
and they lit they live in the forest
like look at their feet
that's incredible
maybe that's the way we should be well
that's a way i think people lived when
they lived in the jungle
forever this is the horror how do you
say that harani
um this is the ecuadorian rainforest
these people this um when you look at
their feet
i think it's soft ground and they're
walking around in dirt all the time
and they their feet splay out
and they develop the ability to like
push off of things
with their feet so it's it's the exact
opposite
of the way human beings develop bunions
or they smush their feet
into like these shoes that don't really
fit human feet
and then they get these weird bunions
where their toes are pointed towards the
other toes
this is the opposite they spread out
like fingers yeah
well we can trace the genetics of this
we become a very weak species
if you get into a a fight with a with
you know let's say a chimp let's say a
house cat even that
bite you offer a dog your face off right
we're at their mercy
but even the strongest human cannot beat
your average chimp or any chimpanzee
pathetic so we're basically a lollipop
physique we're a stick with a big head
but that's because we've had these tools
for so many years we've had fire even
our guts have shrunken down we don't
have long intestine
so we put us out in the wild we're
screwed we can no longer exist in the
wild
yeah but i live in boston i'm out there
in the winter for maybe
10 minutes i'm dead so that's who we are
now we are this pathetic
physical species that has built tools
that are got us here but are actually
messing with our minds
the blue light the chairs we sit in the
food we eat all the time
these have made us a weaker species so
what i'm hoping to do
with my research and and some companies
i'm building
is to get us out of that problem and
engineer our way out and also make
wellness and health
a thing that people actually can take
care of themselves
and what are the steps that what there's
one thing that people can do
and exercise is a good one right because
of the fact that we live these sedentary
lifestyles and most of the time people
are sitting down and
there's a lot of time spent standing at
screens how important do you think it is
to get out and do something and what
kind of an effect does that have like
what kind of quantifiable effect does
that have on life extension
oh it's very clear there are two things
you can do uh that are well known to
extend your lifespan and when i say
extend lifespan i don't mean be older
for longer i mean be healthier in your
80s and 90s
like my dad who's turning 82 who's got
the physique and mental
uh aptitude of a probably a 30 year old
he's stronger than me
so you want that okay so what do you
have to do well you have to start early
you can't just start when you're 80.
although it helps but it's not the best
do you want to just get out of the chair
people say walk but i think it's better
to lose your breath become hypoxic you
know hypoxia chambers hyperbaric
chambers they stress the body a little
bit
so run for 10 minutes a few times a week
that's what i do
um and you don't have to run for hours
it's just 10 minutes is enough
go biking so it's a fact that people who
regularly ride bikes and i think it was
something like
up to 80 miles a week but
they would have a 40 less chance of
having a heart attack than someone who
didn't do that
so it's a massive change not just a
little thing at the margins massive
changes
the other thing is which i do uh is to
skip meals
so it's not that hard i now feel weird
if i eat a meal
for breakfast or lunch and i try not to
snack too this
this idea of nutritionists three meals a
day plus snacks never be hungry
is killing us it really is and we know
that if you do these things to animals
in controlled settings they live longer
a lot longer
20 sometimes 30 percent because they're
healthier for longer they don't get
cancer and heart disease
and dementia so i don't know why we
don't all do that i just think we just
like to sit around and eat
it's it's good it feels good to just eat
chips
do what just feels good oh for sure yeah
but
is there like so when you talk about um
how eating one meal a day
can extend your life is it because
when you're eating all the time you're
taxing your digestive system which taxes
your resources
or is there some sort of a mechanism
that leads to decay of the human body
from over consumption like what is it
yeah so over consumption or just
consumption in general
makes your body complacent and we know
this in great detail at the molecular
level there are genes that respond how
much you're eating
and what you're eating and whether
you're exercising and these are called
longevity genes
and they give our body resilience and
fight aging and slow down
what we can now measure the biological
clock so i can take your blood
or actually now we've developed a very
cheap test just a swab to be able to
tell you very accurately
how old you are not based on how many
times the earth goes around the sun
that's ridiculous
age is just a number you can actually
take the swab i can tell you how
how old you are really but then using
real science tell you how to
slow that down and this is really cool
just in the last few years we've figured
out you can reverse human aging as well
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience